This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. One of the most enduring puzzles of the human brain is that when we look inward, we see what feels like a complete picture. We perceive our feelings, remember memories, and make plans for the future. Over the last several decades, however, psychologists have shown that significant portions of our minds are in fact hidden from us. The operate outside or below the spotlight of conscious awareness. Here's a simple way to demonstrate this.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。人类大脑最持久的谜团之一，就是当我们向内审视时，我们看到的是一个似乎完整的画面。我们感知自己的情感，回忆往事，并为未来做计划。然而，在过去的几十年里，心理学家们已经证明，我们心灵的很大一部分实际上对我们是隐藏的。它们在意识聚光灯之外或下方运作。这里有一个展示这一现象的简单方法。
I'll ask you a question and you give me an answer. Here's the question. Fill in the last word in the sentence. The 4th of July is celebrated as Independence Day in the United States of... ...Blank. Okay, you think. That was too easy. It's the United States of America, of course.
我问你一个问题，你给我一个答案。问题是这样的。补全句子的最后一个词。在美国，7月4日被庆祝为独立日，也就是…………空白处。好吧，你开始思考。这太简单了。当然是美利坚合众国（United States of America）。
But take a moment and reflect on what just happened inside your brain. You heard my question, which is to say, the sound waves carrying my voice entered your ear, were converted into electrical signals and sent to your brain. Neural networks transformed these signals into words, into a sentence, decoded what it meant, and figured out the meaning of the question. Systems in your brain that produce reasoning and memory retrieved the answer to the question. This answer was then routed to centers in the brain that produce language. Other brain systems shaped how your muscles pushed air through your lungs and pushed your
但请花一点时间思考一下你大脑刚才发生了什么。你听到了我的问题，也就是说，承载我声音的声波进入了你的耳朵，被转化为电信号并发送到你的大脑。神经网络将这些信号转化为词语、句子，解码其含义，并弄清楚了问题的意思。你大脑中产生推理和记忆的系统检索出了问题的答案。然后，这个答案被路由到大脑中产生语言的中心。其他大脑系统塑造了你的肌肉如何将空气通过肺部并推动你的
lips, and you came up with America. All those things had to happen for you to come up with the answer, but notice how little you were aware of these many extraordinary feats of neuro-wizardry. The idea that much of our mental lives happens outside of conscious awareness is a key theme across the show. In nearly every hidden brain story, we explore what happens beneath the surface of awareness in the realm of the unconscious, in the kingdom of the implicit. Today on the show, we launch a two-part mini-series.
嘴唇，于是你想出了“美国”。所有这些事情的发生才让你得出答案，但请注意，对于神经奇迹的这些众多非凡壮举，你其实并没有意识到多少。我们的大部分精神生活发生在意识觉察之外，这一观点是贯穿整个节目的核心主题。在几乎每一个“隐藏的大脑”故事中，我们都在意识水面之下、在无意识的领域、在内隐的王国里探索发生了什么。今天的节目中，我们将推出一个两部分的迷你系列。
It's the story of a researcher who has spent a lifetime asking how hidden mental forces shape how we think and what we do. It's also the story of culture, how the thoughts and feelings and actions of millions come together to create the foundation and the fissures of our society. The strange interplay between our minds and the cultures in which we live, this week on Hidden Brain. Imagine if you will, a little girl. It's late at night and she is standing at a second floor balcony at her home in southern India.
这是一个关于一位研究人员的故事，她一生都在探究隐藏的心理力量如何塑造我们的思维和行动。这也是一个关于文化的故事——数百万人的思想、情感和行动如何汇聚在一起，创造了我们社会的基石与裂痕。我们的大脑与我们所生活的文化之间奇妙的相互作用，本周的《隐藏的大脑》为您呈现。请想象一下，如果可以的话，有一个小女孩。那是深夜，她站在印度南部家中二楼的阳台上。
She is doing something strange. She is leaning into the air, her mouth, a gap. I remember a few really, really bad attacks where I would just try to bite into the air to see if I could swallow slightly more air. This is one of Mazarin Banie's earliest memories of the asthma attacks that tormented her as a child. She remembers also the label that came with her struggles. I remember being called a sick child. Our sick child needs X or our sick child needs that and so it was very much a part of my identity that I was a sick child.
她在做一个奇怪的动作。她把身体倾向空气中，嘴巴张得大大的。我记得有几次非常非常严重的哮喘发作，我当时只是试图咬进空气里，看看能不能多吞咽一点空气。这是马扎林·巴纳吉（Mazarin Banaji）对童年折磨她的哮喘发作的最早记忆之一。她还记得伴随着她的挣扎而来的标签。我记得自己被称为一个生病的儿童。我们生病的儿童需要这个，或者我们生病的儿童需要那个，所以“我是个生病的儿童”这一身份深深烙印在我的生活中。
And what that really meant was that I had been born prematurely. I had developed a very severe asthma as a toddler and had a bunch of other autoimmune issues. So yeah, this inability to breathe got me very close to death a few times. And of course, the recovery from that is itself exhausting. And more than me, I think if you talk to my siblings,
而这真正意味着的是，我是早产儿。我在幼儿时期就患上了非常严重的哮喘，还有一堆其他的自身免疫问题。所以，是的，这种无法呼吸的状况曾好几次把我带到死亡的边缘。当然，从那样的病痛中恢复过来本身也是令人精疲力竭的。而且比起我，我想如果你去问我的兄弟姐妹，
they will tell you the trauma that they experienced because their beds were in the same bedroom. And many times, I would leave that room just so they wouldn't have to hear me. Maserine's parents were devoted to her, but didn't have much faith in science and doctors. Instead, they sought out healers from India's many religious faith traditions. So, the one I'll tell you about is a case where somebody was going to come to town and set up on the exhibition grounds in Hyderabad, a cure for many things, including asthma. It required that we leave home at four in the morning,
他们会告诉你他们所经历的创伤，因为他们的床就在同一个卧室里。很多次，我会离开那个房间，这样他们就不用听见我的声音了。马扎林的父母对她疼爱有加，但对科学和医生的信仰却不多。相反，他们四处寻找印度众多宗教信仰传统的治疗师。所以，我要告诉你的其中一个例子是，当时有人要来镇上，在海得拉巴的展览场地上设立一个治疗多种疾病（包括哮喘）的摊位。这要求我们在凌晨四点离开家，
that we get there early, that we then buy an earthenware pot that had water in it and a little fish swimming in it. We would stand in line for hours, and finally we would get to the man who would take the fish, stick something into the fish's mouth from a bowl that he had, like some flour or something, and then open my mouth and have me swallow this live fish. All I could think of was my mother and father love me and they're trying to do something good for me and I'm gonna go and swallow the fish
早早赶到那里，然后买一个装有水和一条小鱼在里面游动陶罐。我们要排几个小时的队，最后我们来到那个男人面前，他会把鱼拿起来，从他拿的一个碗里掏出一些东西（比如一些面粉之类的东西）塞进鱼嘴里，然后打开我的口，让我把这只活鱼吞下去。我脑子里想的只有：我的爸爸妈妈爱我，他们正在努力为我做一件好事，我要去把鱼吞下去，
and then I'm gonna be fine. When that didn't work, Mazareen's mother turned to other healers. To Muslim babas who would have you almost sort of stripped down to your underwear and then kind of whack you with peacock feathers. They were Baptist preachers. They would put their hands on my head and then they would each put their hands on each other's shoulders and then they would pray and then they would sort of speak loudly and call for Jesus and I would be the object of their focus.
然后我就会好起来的。当这不管用时，马扎林的母亲转向了其他治疗师。去找穆斯林巴巴（babas），他们会让你几乎脱得只剩内衣，然后用孔雀羽毛抽打你。他们是浸信会牧师。他们会把手放在我的头上，然后每个人把手放在彼此的肩膀上，接着他们会祈祷，然后大声说话并呼求耶稣，而我成了他们关注的焦点。
Sometimes Maserine would ask herself, how these practitioners were so confident about their measures. How did they know that techniques worked? As her doubts grew, she started running little tests into the efficacy of various interventions. My mother found some little diary of mine from about that time, from the time I was nine years old, in which I had started to write down how poorly I was feeling in terms of my breathing and whether I had prayed a lot or a little. And I think I was trying to create a correlational table. So when I didn't feel very good, sometimes I would pray a little, sometimes I would pray a lot, sometimes I wouldn't pray at all. And what I wanted to see is if that variation was doing anything at all. And so quite early, by the time I was
有时马扎林会问自己，为什么这些行医者对他们的疗法如此自信。他们怎么知道这些技术管用？随着她的疑虑越来越深，她开始对各种干预措施的效用进行一些小测试。我母亲找到了我大约那个时期（从我九岁起）的一些小日记本，我在里面开始写下我的呼吸感觉有多糟糕，以及我祈祷得多还是少。我想我当时是想建立一个相关性表。所以当我感觉不太好时，有时我会祈祷一点，有时我会祈祷很多，有时我根本不祈祷。而我想看看这种差异是否真的起到了什么作用。所以很早的时候，到我九岁或十岁时，
nine or ten, I remember starting to say I didn't want to go to these events. But Mazarene's mother insisted they keep trying. The two of them quarreled. A woman showed up from Boston, Jane Shelton. I remember her very well. She was a white American woman who had come from Boston to preach Christian science in India. And my mother converted, which meant, don't see a doctor. I remember being terrified of Jane Shelton,
我记得我开始说我不想去参加这些活动了。但马扎林的母亲坚持让他们继续尝试。他们母女俩吵过架。一个来自波士顿的女人出现了，简·谢尔顿（Jane Shelton）。我记得她很清楚。她是一个白人美国女性，从波士顿来到印度传扬基督教科学派（Christian Science）。我母亲皈依了，这意味着：不要去看医生。我记得我很怕简·谢尔顿，
because she would come pick us up every Sunday morning to take us to Sunday school, because in that phase we were Christian scientists. Maserine's schooling suffered, as did her emotional well-being. The last time she spent in school, the more she came to feel, like she didn't belong at school. I just didn't have friends. I was intensely lonely. I remember trying to just join a group of girls in the big school that I was attending. And I remember many times that a group of girls were just sort of tight in their circle to physically remove me from it. And they were just being girls,
因为她每个星期天早上都会来接我们去主日学，因为在那个阶段我们是基督教科学派信徒。马扎林的学业受到了影响，她的情感健康也是如此。她在学校呆的时间越长，就越觉得自己在学校里格格不入。我根本没有朋友。我感到无比孤独。我记得我曾试图融入我正在上的那所大学校里的一群女孩中。我也记得很多次，一群女孩只是把她们的圈子缩紧，把我排挤在实体范围之外。她们只是在做女孩，
mean girls maybe, but just girls. But its impact on me was quite traumatic. Even at home, I couldn't go outside. So, you know, if I played in the dust with the other kids or exerted myself, that would bring on, you know, an asthma attack. And so as a result, I was I was forbidden from stepping outdoors. Like many children with limitations, Mazarene found other outlets. Reading came early, and she devoured books in her home, including books she didn't understand.
也许是刻薄的女孩，但也就是女孩。但它对我的影响却是相当创伤性的。甚至在家时，我也不能去外面。所以，你知道，如果我在灰尘里和其他孩子玩耍或过度劳累，就会引发哮喘发作。因此，结果就是我被禁止走到户外。像许多受限制的孩子一样，马扎林找到了其他发泄途径。她很早就开始阅读，并在家中如饥似渴地读书，包括她读不懂的书。
She couldn't play with other kids, but she could watch them. She couldn't play with other kids, but she could watch them. I became an observer of human behavior, in a way in which I could never have had I been a participant. So I had a literal perch on the second floor balcony, and I had this whole panorama of things going on. You know, kids would come back from school and then they would go out and do their play. And I watched them. When events occurred, a fight or something happened, people had very different reactions to it. And so I think I noticed both sort of the general principles of human behavior, not that I was thinking this at all, but also just the variability with which people were responding to the very same thing. When I think back, I do feel that I was almost put in the place of an observer because of that being a sick child.
她不能和其他孩子一起玩，但她可以观察他们。她不能和其他孩子一起玩，但她可以观察他们。我成了一个人类行为的观察者，以一种如果我是参与者就绝无可能的方式。所以我有一个名副其实的二楼阳台的“瞭望台”，我拥有正在发生的事情的全景。你知道，孩子们放学回来然后出去玩。我看着他们。当事件发生时（一场争端或其他事情发生），人们对此有着截然不同的反应。所以我认为我既注意到了人类行为的一般原则（并不是说我当时在思考这些），也注意到了人们对完全相同的事情做出反应时的可变性。现在回想起来，我确实觉得因为当过生病的儿童，我几乎被放在了一个观察者的位置上。
Finally, when she was 16, Mazurine put her foot down with her mother and one. And I remember sort of our big standoff when I was 16 and I said I want to go to see Dr. Menon, who was an alopathic medicine practitioner, a regular doctor. And Dr. Menon was just amazing. He sat me down and he made me a little booklet in which he said, this is what you have, we can control this, you don't have to suffer, use this inhaler. This is nothing more than a pair of sunglasses in the sun or a raincoat in the rain. And I will never forget that. And I could just, I could just feel this feeling of relief that what he was saying and what I was experiencing, that this was right, that in some way this was not something that you can cure, that it is something that you control, and that there are ways to control it. Yeah, but even if you couldn't cure it, the fact that it is actually amenable to change,
终于，在她16岁时，马扎林对母亲态度坚决，并赢得了抗争。我记得当我16岁时，我们有过一次大对峙，我说我想去看门农医生（Dr. Menon），他是一位西医执业者，也就是正规医生。门农医生真是太棒了。他让我坐下来，给我做了一个小册子，里面写着：这就是你的病情，我们可以控制它，你不必受苦，用这个吸入器。这不过是阳光下的一副太阳镜或雨中的一件雨衣。我永远不会忘记这一点。我能感觉到，那种如释重负的感觉——他所说的和我所经历的，这是对的；在某种程度上，这不是一种你能治愈的东西，而是一种你可以控制的东西，并且有办法控制它。是的，但即使你无法治愈它，它实际上可以改变这一事实，
it must have been hugely heartening. It was, but my mother was not happy. So what I found amazing is that the one thing that gave me incredible hope. My mother just almost felt let down by that because to her in her system something as simple as that would just control my asthma. She was on the path for a cure and this would never give me a cure. In time every one of these experiences would come to shape Maasareen's life in important ways. She was to become a professional observer of people. She would come to reject Erie Therese in favor of measurement and evidence. Her insights would prove influential to countless people around
一定是非常令人鼓舞的。确实如此，但我母亲并不高兴。所以我发现惊奇的是，唯一给我带来难以置信希望的事物，我母亲几乎感到失望，因为在她看来，对她的体系而言，像那样简单的事物只会控制我的哮喘。她走在寻找彻底治愈的路上，而这绝不会给我带来治愈。随着时间的推移，这些经历中的每一件都将在重要方面塑造马扎林的人生。她将成为一个专业的人类观察者。她将拒绝虚妄的理论，转而拥抱测量和证据。她的见解将被证明对世界各地的无数人产生了深远的影响。
the world. There was one more early experience that proved transformative in setting Maserine on this path. It happened when she was a university student in India. She was in a train headed home and when the train rolled to a stop, she got off to explore the station. She found a stall selling used books. She wanted a hefty read that would keep her occupied the rest of the journey. I saw five fat red books, said the handbook of social psychology. And the guy said, you know, you can have them for the equivalent, I think of a dollar. I think at the time a dollar was about 30 rupees.
还有早期的一次经历被证明具有变革意义，它让马扎林走上了这条道路。那发生在她是印度的大学生时。她坐在一列回家的火车上，当火车停下时，她下车去探索车站。她发现了一个卖旧书的书摊。她想要一本厚重的读物，好让她在接下来的旅程中打发时间。我看到了五本厚厚的红皮书，上面写着《社会心理学手册》。那个人说，你知道的，你只需要相当于一美元左右的钱就可以拿走它们。我想当时一美元大约是30卢比。
And I think I bargained him down further and found myself carrying five fat books into this train. And on the rest of my ride home, I tried to read the first volume. There were lots of chapters on theory, this and theory that made no sense to me, but there was a chapter called Research Methods in Social Psychology. It was written by a man called Elliot Aronson. And what Elliot had done in this chapter is to talk about the process of doing research. The examples he used were all of these famous experiments
我想我还跟他进一步讨价还价，发现自己带着五本厚厚的书上了这列火车。在剩下的回程中，我试着阅读第一卷。里面有很多关于理论的章节，这个理论那个理论，对我来说毫无意义，但其中有一章叫做《社会心理学中的研究方法》。它是由一个叫埃利奥特·阿伦森（Elliot Aronson）的人写的。埃利奥特在这章中所做的是讲述做研究的过程。他使用的例子全都是这些关于认知失调的著名实验。
on dissonance. And I was just, I think my jaw was just dropping after I heard each of those experiments. And I couldn't believe that there were people somewhere in the world who were actually doing experiments which I had never heard or thought was possible. You can do experiments on particles, you can do experiments on cells, but experiments on social behavior, that had never really even occurred to me as a possibility. And I think there are very few occasions, I don't even know of any other occasion in my life where I felt with some certainty, I must do this. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Maserine Banaji spent a great deal of her childhood with a label attached to her.
我想在听完每一个实验后，我的下巴都要惊掉了。我简直不敢相信，世界上某个地方竟然有人在做实验，而我以前从未听说过或认为这是可能的。你可以对粒子做实验，可以对细胞做实验，但对社会行为做实验，这在我脑海里甚至从未作为一种可能性出现过。我想在我的生命中极少有这样的时刻（我甚至不知道还有没有其他时刻），让我带着某种确信觉得：我必须做这个。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。马扎林·巴纳吉的童年大都在一个贴着标签的环境中度过。
Sick child. Caroff from school and other children, she became an observer of human nature. A chance encounter with a set of used books that she found at a train station in India introduced her to the field of social psychology. Ma'Zerine eventually moved to Ohio State University to work on a PhD. After that, she started teaching at Yale. She focused on the subject of human memory and all the different ways in which memory is shaped by the social world.
生病的儿童。她被学校和其他孩子隔离开来，成了人类本性的观察者。在印度的一个火车站偶然遇到的一套旧书，将她带入了社会心理学领域。马扎林最终搬到了俄亥俄州立大学攻读博士学位。之后，她开始在耶鲁大学教书。她专注于人类记忆的主题，以及记忆被社会世界塑造的所有不同方式。
I had studied memory for emotional information. Why is negative stuff remembered better than positive? So it had always been an interest in memory. It was a focus, I loved that study of memory. And it was towards the end of graduate school and the beginning of my time at Yale, that a revolution was happening in the field of human memory and people were beginning to talk about a second kind of memory that we had not paid attention to for which
我曾研究过关于情感信息的记忆。为什么负面东西比正面东西更容易被记住？所以这一直是我感兴趣的记忆领域。这是一个重点，我热爱对记忆的研究。正是在研究生院的尾声和我在耶鲁大学任教的初期，人类记忆领域正在发生一场革命，人们开始谈论一种我们以前没有注意到的第二种记忆，对此我们现在有了证据，它被称为内隐记忆。
we now had evidence and it was called implicit memory. Scientists had always measured human memory by giving people lists of things to remember and then measuring how well they could recall things from that list. They studied how memory decayed over time. Our recall of things was better right after we had learned something compared to a few weeks later. When researchers talked about memory, this is what they meant. But then new data came in involving people suffering from amnesia, often as the result of some trauma. So they would remember the past really well, but from the moment of the trauma,
科学家们一直通过给人们提供要记住的东西列表，然后衡量他们对该列表内容的记忆效果来衡量人类记忆。他们研究记忆是如何随着时间消逝的。我们对事物的回忆在刚学完某事时比几周后要好。当研究人员谈论记忆时，他们的意思就是指这个。但随后出现了涉及失忆症患者的新数据，这通常是某种创伤的结果。所以他们能把过去记得很清楚，但从创伤发生的那一刻起，
new memories could not get consolidated in them. If you gave these people a list of words and asked them to recall it, they would fail at the task. So you could tell an amnesic patient, you know, what was that list of words I taught you earlier? And they would look at you funnily because they didn't even remember you or the list of words, let alone what the words were. But if you gave them an indirect measure, if you
新的记忆就无法在他们体内巩固。如果你给这些人一个单词列表并要求他们回忆，他们在这个任务上就会失败。所以你可以告诉一个失忆症患者，你知道，我刚才教你的那一串单词是什么？他们会奇怪地看着你，因为他们甚至不记得你或那个单词列表，更不用说那些词是什么了。但如果你给他们一个间接的测量方法，如果你
said, okay, here's a letter M, complete this word with the first word that comes to your mind, that's a five letter word starting with M. And they would say, oh, Motel. And low and behold, Motel had been on the list before. In other words, these patients had stored this information, but they didn't have the usual kind of access to it. And so this implicit form of memory was proving to be incredibly interesting and we realized we had not thought about it or come up with indirect ways of measuring it because we weren't aware that there was this second kind of memory. At a journal club, where scientists shared and talked about interesting papers, Mausereen presented some research on implicit memory by the psychologist Larry Jacobi.
说，好吧，这里有一个字母 M，用你脑海中浮现的第一个词来完成这个词，这是一个以 M 开头的五个字母的词。他们会说，哦，汽车旅馆（Motel）。而奇迹般的是，汽车旅馆以前就在那个列表上。换句话说，这些患者已经储存了这些信息，但他们没有通常的那种获取方式。因此，这种内隐形式的记忆被证明是令人难以置信的有趣，我们意识到我们以前没有考虑过它，也没有想出间接测量它的方法，因为我们不知道还有这第二种记忆的存在。在一个科学家们分享和讨论有趣论文的期刊俱乐部里，马扎林展示了心理学家拉里·雅各比（Larry Jacoby）关于内隐记忆的一些研究。
The title of it was something like becoming famous overnight. And what Larry Jacobi, who I think is one of the most brilliant experimentalists in psychology had done, was to show that these effects we were seeing in amnesic patients were not limited to them. That ordinary people like us also had the same form of implicit memory, but it's very hard to obviously pull it out in us because we also have conscious recollection. Put another way. If both conscious and implicit memory help us to recall something, we notice only the role of conscious memory because implicit memory is hidden from us. How do you detect implicit memory when conscious memory, if you will, stands in front of it. That's
它的标题类似于“一夜成名”。而我认为是心理学中最杰出的实验主义者之一的拉里·雅各比所做的事情，是表明我们在失忆症患者身上看到的这些效应并不局限于他们。像我们这样的普通人也拥有同种形式的内隐记忆，但很显然，要在我们身上把它提取出来非常困难，因为我们同时也有意识回忆。换句话说。如果意识记忆和内隐记忆都帮我们回忆某事，我们通常只注意到意识记忆的作用，因为内隐记忆对我们是隐藏的。当意识记忆（如果你愿意的话）挡在它前面时，你如何检测内隐记忆？这就是
where Larry Jacobi had come up with a clever experiment. He's done this in many different brilliant ways, but this sort of fun experiment, I would say, is one in which he took names out of a phone book. So in those days, we had fat phone books and he went to the phone book and he just pulled out a hundred names of people from the phone book. And he gave them to people to read in his experiment. So they may read a name like Sebastian Weisdorf, happens to be a name from a phone book. Then those same subjects go away
拉里·雅各比想出一个巧妙实验的地方。他以许多不同的绝妙方式做过这件事，但我可以说，这种有趣的实验之一，是他从电话簿里挑选名字。所以在那些日子里，我们有厚厚的电话簿，他走到电话簿前，随便从电话簿里拉出了一百个人的名字。他在他的实验中把这些名字给人们阅读。所以他们可能会读到一个像西巴斯蒂安·韦斯多夫（Sebastian Weisdorf）这样的名字，这恰好是电话簿里的一个名字。然后那些相同的受试者离开，
and they're invited back into the lab 24 or 48 hours later. And when they reappear, Jacobi would present them with a new list of words that contained all the old words they had names they had seen before, like Sebastian Weistorf, but also new names from the phone book, names they had not seen a day or two earlier, and a bunch of famous names thrown in there, names of past precedents, names of actors, names of athletes. So you might, you know, see a name like Ronald Reagan in there, or you might see Wayne Gretzky,
并在24或48小时后被邀请回到实验室。当他们重新出现时，雅各比会向他们展示一张包含所有他们以前见过名字的新单词列表，比如西巴斯蒂安·韦斯多夫，但同时也加入了电话簿里新的名字（他们一两天前没见过的名字），以及一堆名人名字，比如过去总统的名字、演员的名字、运动员的名字。所以你可能会看到像罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）这样的名字，或者你可能会看到韦恩·格雷茨基（Wayne Gretzky），
the hockey player, something. And the subjects, oh, these are all mixed up. So you now have three kinds of names, old names that are not famous, new names that are not famous, and then some famous names. Larry Jacoby asked volunteers to do something very simple. Look at the list of names, and guess which ones were famous people. And what Larry reported in this paper is a very interesting result. Okay, famous names
那个冰球运动员，诸如此类。而受试者，哦，这些全被打乱了。所以你现在有三种名字：不著名的旧名字，不著名的名字，然后是一些著名的名字。拉里·雅各比要求志愿者做一件非常简单的事情。看看名字列表，猜猜哪些是名人。而拉里在这篇论文中报告的是一个非常有趣的结果。好吧，名人名字
will get identified as famous, if you know know them fine, but we're not really interested in them. What we're interested in are the non-famous names on which people make an error, a particular kind of error that we would call if false alarm. And that is, which names are the non-famous names that the subject thought were famous, even though they're not. And his theory said, if you have implicit memory for the list you saw on day one, Sebastian Wyesdorf lingers in your mind, there is some perceptual fluency that you feel for the name. You see it and it looks kind of familiar to you. But you, the subject, you don't know why.
会被识别为名人，如果你认识他们那很好，但我们真的对他们不感兴趣。我们感兴趣的是那些人们会犯错的不著名名字——一种我们会称之为“虚报”（false alarm）的特定错误。也就是说，受试者认为是名人但实际上不是名人的那些不著名名字有哪些。他的理论说：如果你对第一天看到的列表有内隐记忆，西巴斯蒂安·韦斯多夫就会在你的脑海中挥之不去，你会对这个名字产生某种感知流畅性。你看到了它，它对你来说看起来有点面熟。但你（受试者）不知道为什么。
Is this name looking familiar to me because I saw it the day before? Or, you know, is this, say, movie star that, you know, whose name is familiar because I've seen it on a screen? Larry Jacoby found volunteers mistakenly thought names they had seen the previous day were famous people. What was happening was that even though they did not consciously remember the names they had seen from the phone book,
这个名字对我看起来眼熟是因为我前一天见过它吗？还是说，你知道的，这是一个电影明星，你知道的，因为我在银幕上看过所以名字很熟？拉里·雅各比发现，志愿者们错误地认为他们前一天见过的名字是名人。发生的情况是，尽管他们没有有意识地记住他们从电话簿里看到的名字，
they retained implicit memory of those names. Confronted a second time with these names, the names now look familiar. Since we tend to associate familiar names with famous people, the volunteers thought these names belong to famous people. You are likely to make a mistake and identify Sebastian Weistorf as famous, wrongly. So that's why he called him becoming famous overnight. And that was the paper, and I presented that paper.
但他们保留了对这些名字的内隐记忆。第二次面对这些名字时，这些名字现在看起来很熟悉了。由于我们倾向于将熟悉的名字与名人联系起来，志愿者们认为这些名字属于名人。你很可能会犯错，错误地将西巴斯蒂安·韦斯多夫识别为名人。这就是为什么他把它叫做“一夜成名”。这就是那篇论文，我展示了那篇论文。
And it just stayed with me long enough that I thought, you know, by the way, I was, I think I was in my second or third year as an assistant professor by this time, and I'm making no progress on anything. I'm not, I don't have a, you know, I'm doing stuff, but it wasn't like there was anything I was identified with that was going anywhere. So I thought, you know, obviously I'm interested in memory, implicit memory is clearly interesting. Let me start by replicating the Jacobi experiment. Maizuri noticed that all the names that Larry Jacobi had used in his experiment were male names.
它在我脑海里停留了足够长的时间，以至于我想，你知道，顺便说一句，我当时大约是担任助理教授的第二年或第三年，我在任何事情上都没有取得进展。我没有，你知道我在做事情，但并不是说有什么我被认同的东西正在取得进展。所以我想，显然我对记忆感兴趣，内隐记忆显然很有趣。让我从复制雅各比的实验开始。马扎林注意到，拉里·雅各比在他的实验中使用的所有名字都是男性名字。
In her replication of the experiment, she included female names from the phone book. She fully expected to find exactly what the senior psychologists had found. And so the first study results came back and showed Jacoby's result, but it was restricted to male names. Male names did become famous overnight, so Bastion Roy's Dorf was more likely to be identified as famous, but in my case, Stephanie Roy's Dorf was not. Why would male names from the phone book that the volunteers had seen a day or two earlier be seen as famous, but female names from the very same phone book not be seen this way? Maserid was not interested in studying questions of bias, but the data told her that bias was at work.
在她对该实验的复制中，她把电话簿里的女性名字也包括了进去。她满以为会发现与资深心理学家完全相同的结果。于是第一项研究结果出来了，显示了雅各比的结果，但它仅限于男性名字。男性名字确实一夜成名了，所以巴斯蒂安·韦斯多夫（Bastion Roy's Dorf）更有可能被识别为名人，但在我的案例中，斯蒂芬妮·韦斯多夫（Stephanie Roy's Dorf）却没有。为什么志愿者一两天前见过的电话簿里的男性名字会被看作名人，而来自同一电话簿的女性名字却不会被这样看待呢？马扎林本来对研究偏见问题不感兴趣，但数据告诉她，偏见正在起作用。
Volunteers were using the filter of gender to reach their conclusions. I started to quiz people after every experiment, after the first one. So in experiments two, three, four, five, I would ask every single subject at the end of the study, I would say, what rule did you use to make your decision? And they would tell me. And if they didn't say anything about gender, I would say,
志愿者们在使用性别的过滤器来得出他们的结论。我在每个实验后都会盘问人们，在第一个实验之后。所以在实验二、三、四、五中，我会在研究结束时询问每一个受试者，我会说，你用什么规则来做决定？他们会告诉我。如果他们没有说任何关于性别的话，我会说，
did you use gender in making your decision? And they would look horrified and say, of course not. And yet in their data, it was clear that they had. So, for me, that's when the light bulb went off and I thought if this is true, if people are doing this without any awareness, it's got to be pretty pervasive. Evolentures were misapplying the filter of gender in a lab experiment involving names in a phone book, where else might they misapply the same filter? Could it shape how managers made hiring decisions, in medical treatment, in classrooms? Maserine had only to look around, of course, to see conscious sexism.
你在做决定时使用性别了吗？他们会看起来很惊恐并说，当然没有。然而在他们的数据中，很明显他们用了。所以，对我来说，这就是灯泡亮起的时候，我想如果这是真的，如果人们在没有任何意识的情况下这样做，它一定是非常普遍的。志愿者在一个涉及电话簿中名字的实验室实验中错误地应用了性别的过滤器，他们还会在哪里错误地应用同样的过滤器呢？它会塑造管理者做出招聘决策的方式吗？在医疗中？在课堂上？马扎林当然只需环顾四周，就能看到有意识的性别歧视。
TV shows and books and political debates were filled with open misogyny. Let me just say first of all that I almost resent Vice President Bush your patronizing attitude that you have to teach me about foreign policy. What's my boy doing with the Barbie? I've got to determine what your motivation might be. Are you a scorned woman? Don't consider age in the face of cleavage. This occurs on a molecular level. You can't control it. But what had happened in this experiment was more interesting and more troubling.
电视节目、书籍和政治辩论中充斥着公开的厌女症。首先我想说的是，我几乎对副总统布什先生你那种居高临下的态度感到不满，你居然得教我外交政策。我的男孩拿着芭比娃娃在干什么？我得确定你的动机可能是什么。你是一个被抛弃的女人吗？不要在乳沟面前考虑年龄。这是发生在分子水平上的。你无法控制它。但在这个实验中发生的事情更有趣，也更令人不安。
It showed that people could be biased without any awareness of being biased. In many ways, this was worse than garden variety sexism because the people who had the bias felt they were unbiased. If implicit biases are hidden outside of conscious view, how do you reliably reveal their presence? Doctors run blood tests to measure cholesterol levels. Ma'am Zureen wants a test that could similarly measure implicit bias. She and her colleagues began to develop ideas. So for the next two years, I know that the Jacobi procedure is fine, but you need something where fame is not the main decision you have to get at something closer to the association.
它表明人们可能在毫无意识自己有偏见的情况下产生偏见。在许多方面，这比普通的性别歧视更糟糕，因为有偏见的人觉得自己是没有偏见的。如果内隐偏见隐藏在意识视野之外，你如何可靠地揭示它们的存在？医生通过验血来测量胆固醇水平。马扎林想要一个能以同样方式测量内隐偏见的测试。她和她的同事开始构思想法。所以在接下来的两年里，我知道雅各比的程序很好，但你需要一个地方，声誉不是你必须做出的主要决定，你得找到更接近联想的东西。
Ma Zareen presented volunteers with words like Chairman or Chairwoman. She found that saying Chairman subsequently made masculine concepts more accessible to volunteers and using Chairwoman made feminine concepts more accessible. In many ways, this is intuitively obvious. When we hear the word salt, it's easier to bring to mind the word pepper rather than the word dinosaur. We've seen salt and pepper linked together so many times that we have formed an implicit association between the two words. What Mausurine and her colleagues were finding was that by measuring the speed of people's associations,
马扎林向志愿者提供了诸如“主席（Chairman）”或“女主席（Chairwoman）”之类的词。她发现，说“Chairman”随后会使男性的概念更容易被志愿者联想到，而使用“Chairwoman”则会使女性的概念更容易被联想到。在许多方面，这在直觉上是显而易见的。当我们听到“盐”这个词时，更容易让人联想到“胡椒”而不是“恐龙”这个词。我们看到盐和胡椒被联系在一起很多次，以至于我们在两个词之间形成了内隐联想。马扎林和她的同事们发现的是，通过测量人们联想的速度，
they could peer into people's minds and tell which associations were strong and which ones were weak. In 1994, Mazerine's PhD advisor, Tony Greenwald, now at the University of Washington and a collaborator on the implicit bias research, sent her an email. Tony is very terns. He writes brief emails.
他们可以窥视人们的心灵，并分辨出哪些联想是强烈的，哪些是微弱的。1994年，马扎林的博士生导师托尼·格林沃尔德（Tony Greenwald，现就职于华盛顿大学，也是内隐偏见研究的合作者）给她发了一封电子邮件。托尼非常简短。他写简短的电子邮件。
I got an email with a little program and all he said is try this. Tony had come up with a list of insects and a list of flowers. Words from these lists popped up on Maasareen's screen. Insect and flower and if an insect pops up I should say left and if a flower pops up I should say right and I just use the two keys, E for left, I for right and it's very simple. If I see rows I say it's a flower and I press the left key. If it says bug or something like that, I say right key. Maasareen blazed through the test. It was ridiculously easy. Next, Tony had her classifier set of words as positive or negative words.
我收到了一封带有小程序的电子邮件，他唯一说的就是：试试这个。托尼列出了一张昆虫清单和一张花卉清单。来自这些列表的单词出现在马扎林的屏幕上。昆虫和花，如果出现昆虫，我应该说“左”，如果出现花，我应该说“右”，我只用两个键：E代表左，I代表右，这很简单。如果我看到玫瑰，我说这是一朵花，我按左键。如果上面写着虫子或类似的东西，我说右键。马扎林迅速完成了测试。这简直太简单了。接下来，托尼让她将一组词分类为正面或负面词汇。
This is very easy. How hard is it to say a word like peace is a good word? How hard is it to say that a word like nasty is a bad word? You can do that too. You can use two keys to say which one's good and which one's bad. A third grader would have no trouble with the task. The next part of the test asked Mazerine to group together all the flower words with all the positive words. If she saw either rose or piece, she had to press the left key.
这非常简单。说“和平”是一个好词有多难？说“讨厌”是一个坏词有多难？你也能做到这一点。你可以用两个键来分辨哪个好哪个坏。三年级的小学生做这个任务也不会有任何问题。测试的下一部分要求马扎林将所有的花卉词与所有的正面词归为一组。如果她看到玫瑰或和平，她必须按左键。
If she saw either bug or nasty, she had to press the right key. This was also really easy to do. Then came the twist. Tony asked Maserine to group all the flowers with negative words on one side and the insects with positive words on the other. Effectively, the test was asking Maserine to link together words like bug and cockroach with words like peace and joy. Since most of us don't associate insects with positive concepts,
如果她看到虫子或讨厌的东西，她必须按右键。这也是非常容易做到的。然后反转来了。托尼要求马扎林将一侧的所有花与消极词汇归为一组，将另一侧的昆虫与积极词汇归为一组。实际上，测试要求马扎林将“虫子”、“蟑螂”等词与“和平”、“快乐”等词联系起来。由于我们大多数人不把昆虫和积极的概念联系起来，
it took Maserine more effort to do this part of the test. And you realize that it is not at all easy to do. You're making mistakes. You're taking long to do it. And you feel the failure of your brain. You're feeling it in real time that your brain has just stopped working. As she did the test, Ma'Zerine already understood why this last section was hard.
马扎林花了更多精力来做测试的这一部分。你会意识到这根本不容易做到。你正在犯错。你花了很长时间去做。你感受到了大脑的失灵。你正在实时感受到你的大脑刚刚停止了工作。当她做这个测试时，马扎林已经明白了为什么最后一部分很难。
Implicitly, hidden away from conscious view, we have a set of associations with flowers and insects. Our associations with flowers and insects. Our associations with flowers are generally positive. Our associations with insects are generally negative. There was a second test Tony had included in his email. There were positive and negative words as before, but now, instead of flowers and insects, Tony gave Maasareen a list of names traditionally used by black people and a list of names traditionally used by white people. He asked her to pair white names with positive words and black names with negative words.
内隐地，隐藏在意识视野之外，我们对花卉和昆虫有一套联想。我们对花卉和昆虫的联想。我们对花卉的联想通常是积极的。我们对昆虫的联想通常是消极的。托尼的电子邮件中还包括第二个测试。像以前一样有积极和消极的词汇，但现在，托尼没有给马扎林提供花卉和昆虫，而是给了她一份黑人传统上常用的名字列表和一份白人传统上常用的名字列表。他要求她将白人名字与积极词汇配对，将黑人名字与消极词汇配对。
Maasareen found this was as easy to do as pairing flowers with positive words and insects with negative words. Then Tony flipped the groupings. He asked Maasurine to pair white names with negative words and black names with positive words. I've already done the insect flower task so I know that aha, I see what we're doing here, but I'm not prepared at all for the pit in my stomach that I'm going to experience when I come to the moment when I have to associate quite with bad and black with good. Even how shall I say this? I knew what this test was trying to do. I've done dozens of these kinds of things before,
马扎林发现这和将花与积极词汇配对、将昆虫与消极词汇配对一样容易。然后托尼颠倒了分组。他要求马扎林将白人名字与消极词汇配对，将黑人名字与积极词汇配对。我已经做过昆虫花卉任务，所以我知道“啊哈，我明白我们在做什么了”，但我完全没有准备好去体验那种胃下坠的感觉，当我来到必须将白色与坏、黑色与好的那一刻时。甚至，我该怎么说呢？我知道这个测试在试图做什么。我以前做过几十次这种事情，
but there was something about that moment that I say even today, it was the single most transformative moment in my life. The test was telling me that my mind could not associate black with good as easily as it could associate white with good. That is not my view of myself. That is to say, I believe that if I choose to, I can associate anything with good and with that. It's up to me to decide what I want to do. This test took away all of that.
但那一刻有一种说不出的感觉，即使在今天我也会说，那是我一生中最具变革意义的时刻。测试告诉我，我的大脑不能像把白色与好联系起来那样轻易地把黑色与好联系起来。这不是我对自己的看法。也就是说，我相信如果我选择的话，我可以把任何东西与好和坏联系起来。由我来决定我想做什么。这个测试夺走了这一切。
This test said you can try to do that, but I'm gonna show you you really cannot do certain things as easily as you can do others, and as a psychologist, I knew that that is meant something more than just ease of doing the test. It meant that my brain had received the thumbprint of the culture so deeply that I had no control over this. The feeling was a feeling of dread. I would say a feeling of having had the rug pulled out from under you. This is like a moral death that you're experiencing because everything you've believed is being taken apart in front of your very eyes and you are left with nothing. You have to start from scratch to now rebuild a view of yourself that will forever be a different view of yourself.
这个测试说你可以尝试这样做，但我要向你展示你真的无法像轻易做其他事情那样轻易地做到某些事情，作为一个心理学家，我知道这不仅仅意味着做测试的轻松程度。这意味着我的大脑深深地接收了文化的指纹，以至于我对这个毫无控制力。这种感觉是一种恐惧感。我会说这是一种地毯被从你脚下抽走的感觉。这就像你正在经历精神上的死亡，因为你所相信的一切都在你的眼前被拆解，你什么也没剩下。你不得不从头开始，重新建立一个对自己的看法，这个看法将永远是一个不同的自我看法。
It was a painful moment, but it was also the beginning of a profound turning point in Mazareens' career. She and Tony Greenwald would take this insight about our minds and develop a now famous test. It's one that millions of people around the world have taken to try to better understand the workings of their minds. When we come back, Maserine's work receives the kind of attention most scientists never dream of. But not all of it is positive. You know, enough of this seeking every opportunity to demean law enforcement broadly by making the accusation of implicit bias every time tragedy.
这是一个痛苦的时刻，但它也是马扎林职业生涯中深刻转折点的开始。她和托尼·格林沃尔德将把这种关于我们思想的洞察力发展成一个现已著名的测试。这是世界各地数百万人为了更好地了解自己思维运作方式而参加的测试。当我们回来时，马扎林的工作受到了大多数科学家做梦也想不到的关注。但并非所有的关注都是积极的。你知道的，每次发生悲剧时，都借口指责内隐偏见，以此来贬低广泛的执法部门，这种寻找一切机会的做法已经够了。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. After Tony Greenwall sent Maserine Banalji the test that revealed her own hidden biases to her, they and other researchers took this insight and developed something called the Implicit Association Test. It measures our hidden associations. Tests like the one Mazarin Tuk have now been used by millions of people. They offer a window into the minds of Americans, and not everyone likes what they see. After Mazarin Banagy moved to Harvard University, the school began hosting a number of her tests at a website, implicit.harvard.edu.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在托尼·格林沃尔德向马扎林·巴纳吉发送了那个向她揭示她自己隐藏偏见的测试之后，他们和其他研究人员利用这一见解开发了所谓的内隐联想测验。它测量我们的隐藏联想。像马扎林参加的那样的测试现在已被数百万人使用。它们提供了一扇了解美国人思想的窗口，并不是每个人都喜欢他们所看到的东西。在马扎林·巴纳吉搬到哈佛大学后，该校开始在网站 implicit.harvard.edu 上托管她的许多测试。
The tests are free and can be taken by anyone with a computer and an internet connection. People around the world have taken tests that measure their attitudes about race and sexual orientation. Other tests measure implicit attitudes about the poor, the elderly, and people who are overweight. Almost from the start, the implicit association test, or IAT, produced strong reactions. Many people responded with shame, guilt, and anger. Others hailed the test, saying it could explain vast disparities we see in societies today, including in communities of people who pride themselves on being deeply egalitarian. In the early days of the test, a physician named Alexander Greene reached out to Maserid.
这些测试是免费的，任何拥有电脑和互联网连接的人都可以参加。世界各地的人们都参加了测量他们对种族和性取向态度的测试。其他测试则测量对穷人、老年人和超重人群的内隐态度。几乎从一开始，内隐联想测验（IAT）就产生了强烈的反应。许多人以羞耻、内疚和愤怒作出回应。其他人则称赞该测试，称它可以解释我们在当今社会中看到的巨大差异，包括在那些以身为深度平等主义者而自豪的社群中。在测试的早期，一位名叫亚历山大·格林（Alexander Greene）的医生联系了马扎林。
Alex, who worked in a medical school, was interested in this question of whether implicit bias might be playing a role in the decisions of medical professionals, because in his experience, medical professionals are among the most egalitarian people we know, he said. This is a profession that takes an oath. And yet, if you look at the data, we now have not dozens but hundreds of studies that have been done looking at many kinds of disparities, but especially at racial disparities in health care.
在医学院工作的亚历克斯对内隐偏见是否在医疗专业人员的决策中起作用这个问题很感兴趣，因为根据他的经验，医疗专业人员是我们所知的最讲究平等的人之一，他说。这是一个宣过誓的职业。然而，如果你看看数据，我们现在拥有的不是几十个，而是数百个研究，这些研究着眼于多种类型的差异，尤其是医疗保健中的种族差异。
And so he was puzzled by this. How is it possible that these people who try so hard every day to overcome the challenges that are being posed by racism are in their own behavior showing certain systematic effects that mimic the very thing that they would criticize. And then maybe it is not conscious bias, but that there is a certain kind of bias that we can now measure that may be playing a role. Maasareen and Alex gave doctors in Atlanta and Boston a case study, a medical scenario. It described a Mr. Thompson who comes into the hospital complaining of chest pains. The case study gave a medical history of Mr. Thompson and asked the physicians if they
这让他感到十分困惑。为什么这些每天都在努力克服种族主义带来的种种挑战的人，在他们自己的行为中，也会表现出某些模仿他们所批评对象的系统性效应呢？也许这并不是有某种有意识的偏见，而是某种我们现在可以测量的偏见在起作用。马萨林和亚历克斯给亚特兰大和波士顿的医生们提供了一个案例研究，一个医疗场景。其中描述了一位汤普森先生，他来到医院主诉胸痛。案例研究给出了汤普森先生的病史，并询问医生他们是否
would prescribe clot-busting treatments that could prevent a stroke. All the physicians saw the same case study except that some were told Mr. Thompson was white and others were told he was black. Everything is the same. It's just that the person is either black or white, but the data that you see are the same. And the medical professional is asked, would you prescribe thrombolysis, which I believe is prescribed in some cases that present with these symptoms?
会开出能够预防中风的溶栓药物。所有的医生看到的都是同一个案例研究，除了部分医生被告知汤普森先生是白人，而其他人则被告知他是黑人。其他一切都完全一样。只是这个人的种族一个是黑人或白人，但你看到的数据是完全一样的。医学专业人员被问及，你会开出溶栓药吗？我相信在出现这些症状的某些情况下，这是会被开出来的。
The researchers found a small racial disparity. Physicians were slightly less likely to recommend the clot-busting treatments to the black Mr. Thompson compared to the white Mr. Thompson. But when the researchers had the physicians take an implicit association test or IAT, a curious pattern emerged. When you add in the IAT, what you saw is that doctors who showed Then the IAT, what you saw, is that doctors who showed higher anti-black bias on the IAT were also the ones who decided to withhold thrombolitis to black patients. Soon, new data was coming in on multiple fronts. One question Maserine had was when these biases get into people's heads.
研究人员发现了一个微小的种族差异。与白人汤普森先生相比，医生对黑人汤普森先生推荐溶栓治疗的可能性略低。但当研究人员让医生进行内隐联想测验（IAT）时，一个有趣的模式出现了。当你加入IAT时，你所看到的是，在IAT上表现出更高反黑人偏见的医生，同时也正是那些决定对黑人患者不予溶栓治疗的人。很快，来自多方面的新数据不断涌现。马萨林心中的一个问题是，这些偏见究竟是什么时候进入人们脑海的。
No one is born with these biases, so are they learned in early childhood, in adolescence, in adulthood? After Mazarin moved to Harvard, she started running experiments comparing six-year-olds, 10-year-olds, and adults. And I assumed at that time that the data would show that five and six-year-olds would show no bias at all because their experience in the world on race in particular, these are kids in Cambridge. This is not a city with a large black population,
没有人是生来就带有这些偏见的，那么它们是在幼儿时期、青春期还是成年期学到的呢？马萨林搬到哈佛大学后，开始进行对比实验，比较了6岁儿童、10岁儿童和成年人。当时我以为数据会显示，5岁和6岁的孩子根本不会表现出任何偏见，因为他们在世俗生活中对种族尤其是这方面的经验很少，这些是剑桥的孩子。这不是一个拥有大量黑人人口的城市，
that these are kids who would show no bias at all. It should be zero. And then maybe 10 year olds have picked up a little bit and then to compare those two, we picked adults at the same time. So we could get data from three groups, six year olds, six year olds, ten year olds, and adults. And we also asked them questions, of course, you know, if you
这些孩子应该完全不会表现出偏见。数值应当为零。然后也许10岁的孩子会沾染了一点，为了作对比，我们同时挑选了成年人。这样我们就可以从三组人那里获得数据：6岁儿童、10岁儿童和成年人。当然，我们也会问他们一些问题，比如，如果你
have two people in front of you, which one do you prefer? The researchers showed volunteers two photos. One showed a black person, the other showed a white person. So that was the explicit measure, the one where you could exert conscious awareness if you wanted to and say whatever you feel is right for you. On the explicit measure, adults told Mazreen they had no preferences at all. They liked the blackface and whiteface equally. This is in line with other reports that find very few Americans admit to having racial biases of any kind.
面前有两个人，你更喜欢哪一个？研究人员向志愿者展示了两张照片。一张是一个黑人，另一张是一个白人。这就是显性测量，也就是如果你愿意，你可以施加有意识的意识，并说出任何你觉得对你来说正确的话。在显性测量上，成年人告诉马萨林他们没有任何偏好。他们对黑人和白人的喜爱程度是一样的。这与其它报告相一致，这些报告发现极少有美国人承认自己有任何形式的种族偏见。
10-year-olds are showing a little bit of bias favoring their own group. So when asked, they would say, I like, you know, they would try to pick equally, but they tended to prefer white if they were white. And in this study, it was only white kids, the first one. Six-year-olds were just honest. They would just pick the white kid much of the time,
10岁的孩子表现出了一点偏见，倾向于支持他们自己的群体。因此当被问到时，他们会说，我喜欢，你知道的，他们会试图做出平等的选择，但如果他们是白人，他们往往会更喜欢白人。在这项研究中，最初只有白人小孩。6岁的小孩则表现得非常诚实。在很多时候，他们只是选择白人小孩，
80% of the time. They were saying, so what we saw was, in fact, quite clear differences in explicit with the greatest bias being expressed by six-year-olds, slightly less biased, expressed by 10-year-olds, and adults being completely neutral. Then the researchers turned to the IAT data. Would there be a difference between six-year-olds and adults being completely neutral. Then the researchers turned to the IAT data. Would there be a difference between six-year-olds, 10-year-olds, and adults when it came to their implicit associations on race? Mazarin thought she would find the youngest children had no implicit bias. The older children would have some, and then adults would have a lot of it. If implicit associations are picked up by being exposed to people from different walks of
80%的时间都是如此。他们是在说，因此我们看到的是，在显性测量中实际上存在着相当明显的差异，表现出最大偏见的是6岁儿童，其次是10岁儿童，而成年人则完全保持中立。接着研究人员转向了IAT数据。6岁儿童、10岁儿童和成年人在对种族的内隐联想方面会有区别吗？马萨林以为她会发现年纪最小的孩子没有内隐偏见。稍大的孩子会有一点，然后成年人会有很多。如果内隐联想是通过接触来自不同背景的人而获得的，
life, wouldn't this be what you'd expect? And we did not see that. The data showed, you know, almost millisecond level similarity in the data of six-year-olds, 10-year-olds, and adults. In other words, the six-year-olds in white culture looked like white adults. No different from them. It changed my view about what it is that the IAT might be tapping into. And it told me that what this test is tapping into is something that emerges early in life and whether you have seen any people and know any people in those groups or not, you are going to show this bias. The test revolutionized the study of bias seemingly overnight. Within a few short years, companies were mandating employees take Maasurin's tests to help employees identify their implicit biases. A vast training industry popped up
难道这不正是你所预期的吗？然而我们并没有看到这一点。数据显示，6岁儿童、10岁儿童和成年人的数据在毫秒级上几乎是相似的。换句话说，白人文化中的6岁儿童看起来就像白人成年人。与他们没有任何区别。这改变了我对IAT可能在探测什么的看法。它告诉我，这个测试所探测的是在生命早期就出现的东西，不管你是否见过或认识这些群体中的任何人，你都会表现出这种偏见。这个测试几乎在一夜之间彻底改变了偏见研究。在短短几年内，许多公司强制员工参加马萨林的测试，以帮助员工识别他们的内隐偏见。一个庞大的培训行业应运而生，
offering to help people rid themselves of their unconscious biases. Social justice advocates seized on the tests. Here finally was a way to explain vast disparities they were seeing in classrooms, in healthcare settings, and in the criminal justice system. But even as some people were excited by the potential of the test to transform social policy, others were increasingly upset. Some researchers felt that claims about the IAT and what it could tell us were going too far too fast. And one study started to show that conservative parts of the United States had larger implicit biases than liberal places, the tests exploded
声称可以帮助人们摆脱无意识的偏见。社会正义倡导者也抓住了这些测试不放。这终于提供了一种方法来解释他们在教室、医疗机构和刑事司法系统中看到的巨大差异。但正当一些人对该测试改变社会政策的潜力感到兴奋时，另一些人却日益感到不安。一些研究人员认为，关于IAT及其能够告诉我们的信息的声称走得太快、太远了。一项研究开始表明，美国保守派地区的内隐偏见比自由派地区更大，这些测试引发了
into political controversy. The pinnacle of the controversy came in 2016 when presidential candidate Hillary Clinton said she thought implicit biases were widespread across society. This was during a debate with Republican candidate Donald Trump. Too many of us in our great country jumped to conclusions about each other. And therefore I think we need all of us to be asking hard questions about, you know, why am I feeling this way? But when it comes to policing, since it can have literally fatal consequences,
巨大的政治争议。这场争议的顶峰出现在2016年，当时总统候选人希拉里·克林顿表示，她认为内隐偏见在整个社会中普遍存在。这是在与共和党候选人唐纳德·特朗普的辩论中提到的。在我们伟大的国家里，我们有太多人对彼此妄下结论。因此，我认为我们需要所有人都提出严厉的问题，比如，为什么我会产生这种感觉？但当涉及到警务工作时，因为它可能会产生字面意义上的致命后果，
I have said in my first budget, we would put money into that budget to help us deal with implicit bias by retraining a lot of our police officers. A few days later, during the vice presidential debate, Republican Mike Pence brought up the topic during his debate with Democratic Senator Tim Cain. He said law enforcement personnel were feeling vilified by accusations of implicit bias. What we ought to do is we ought to stop seizing on these moments of tragedy.
我在我的第一个预算中说过，我们将在该预算中投入资金，通过对许多警察进行再培训，来帮助我们应对内隐偏见。几天后，在副总统辩论期间，共和党人迈克·彭斯在与民主党参议员蒂姆·凯恩的辩论中再次提出了这个话题。他说，执法人员因内隐偏见指控而感到被污名化。我们应该做的是，我们应该停止抓住这些悲剧时刻不放。
We ought to assure the public that we'll have a full and complete and transparent investigation whenever there's a loss of life because of police action. But Senator, please, enough of this seeking every opportunity to demean law enforcement broadly
我们应该向公众保证，每当由于警察执法而发生生命损失时，我们都会进行全面、完整和透明的调查。但是参议员，拜托，不要再抓住每一个机会，通过在每一次悲剧发生时
by making the accusation of implicit bias every time tragedy. So on the one hand, Maserine, it's kind of extraordinary that work done in an academic lab is getting debated in a presidential and vice presidential debate. That is kind of extraordinary. And I think most researchers would be, would never dream of something like that happening. But what did you hear when Mike Penn said these words under the National Spotlight? I remember where I was when I heard it. It's a flash bulb memory. I was in my home with all my graduate students. Our jaws just dropped. They're talking about our little work. Like we're, I would say that I have never gotten accustomed to this. This is now, this happens so frequently, I'll be on an airplane and I'll look at the
都指责内隐偏见，来广泛地贬低执法人员了。所以一方面，马萨林，在学术实验室完成的工作竟然能在总统和副总统辩论中被讨论，这真是非同寻常。这确实很不寻常。我想大多数研究人员做梦也不会想到会发生这种事。但是，当迈克·彭斯在聚光灯下说出这些话时，你听到了什么？我记得我听到时身在何处。这是一段闪光灯记忆。我和所有的研究生都在家里。我们的下巴都惊掉了。他们在谈论我们那点小小的研究。就像我们是，我会说我从来没有习惯过这一点。现在这发生得太频繁了，我会在飞机上看着
little TV screen. And the first thing I'll see is somebody saying something about implicit bias and helping is this a candid camera experiment being done to see what I'm going to do. So it is everywhere, it has now become a common place. It has gotten into enough places that there is a play, there are entire art exhibits, there's a poem, there's a musical score that's been written. So there's a whole bunch of stuff in the arts that's been happening on this concept. Every organization, worth its name, has some program devoted to teaching people about
小电视屏幕。我看到的第一个画面就是有人在谈论内隐偏见，并帮着看这是否是为了观察我会做什么而进行的隐藏摄像机实验。所以它无处不在，现在已经成了一种司空见惯的现象。它已经进入了足够多的地方，以至于出现了一部戏剧、整个艺术展览、一首诗、甚至还谱写了一首交响乐。所以在艺术领域有很多围绕这个概念的创作在发生。每一个名副其实的组织都有专门的节目来教导人们
this. So what we're seeing here is an enormous attraction to a way of understanding something that had been impossible to even identify previously. And I think overall, I would say, the reaction is teach it to us so we can do better. We are ready, we're not scared. And depends on how you do it, I think there's a ton of really terrible
了解这一点。因此，我们在这里看到的是，人们对一种理解某种以前甚至无法识别的事物的方法产生了巨大的吸引力。总的来说，我认为我的反应是：教给我们吧，这样我们可以做得更好。我们准备好了，我们并不害怕。这取决于你如何去做，我认为有大量非常糟糕的
diversity training. I would challenge the teaching of much of what is taught in the name of implicit bias. But let's go back to the debate. Hillary Clinton actually had an answer to that question. And she said, it's in all of us. And as a result result even in the police and we should do something about it. That's the rational answer because that's what the research
多元化培训。我对以内隐偏见名义教授的很多内容提出质疑。但让我们回到辩论上来。希拉里·克林顿实际上对这个问题做出了回答。她说，它存在于我们所有人身上。因此，甚至连警察身上也有，我们应该做点什么。这是一个理性的答案，因为这就是研究所
shows. Not everybody has everybody as an exactly the same amount but if you take you know four or five tests the overwhelming likelihood is that 100% of people will show a bias on some test or the other. So if I were Mike Pence, I would have said, isn't it remarkable that we find that there are not just a few bad apples here or there? It actually in some way should be relieving to find out that we are all in this together, that this is a problem that sits at the feet of the nation. To me, what will be much more frightening is to point fingers, to say, there is that person there who is biased and this person here who is not. If you think you have five bad police officers
显示的结果。并不是每个人都有完全相同数量的偏见，但如果你参加四五个测试，绝大多数可能性是100%的人都会在某个或某些测试中表现出偏见。所以如果我是迈克·彭斯，我会说，难道不是很了不起吗？我们发现这里并不只有几个害群之马。从某种程度上说，发现我们都在这条船上，这是一个根源于整个国家的问题，其实应该是一种解脱。对我来说，更可怕的是互相指责，说“那个人有偏见，而这个人没有”。如果你认为在两百人的警队里有五个坏警察，
in a force of 200 and your job is to ferret them out, your bar is not very high and you should be able to get rid of those five and be fine. But you are not. And the reason you are not is because not only is it invisible and in each mind, it is now in the organization and it means for the tentacles of implicit bias to spread through an organization or a country. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura
而你的工作是把他们揪出来，你的标准其实并不高，你应该能够摆脱那五个人然后一切就没事了。但你却没有。而你之所以没有这样做，是因为它不仅看不见且存在于每个人的头脑中，它现在已经渗透到了整个组织中，这意味着内隐偏见的触角已经蔓延到了整个组织或国家。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、阿尼·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·
Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks on this episode to Sound Designer Nick Woodbury. Our unsung hero today comes from our sister podcast My Unsung Hero. It comes from listener Majeed Hajj. In 2004 Majeed moved his family from Iran to Washington State. In 2004, Majeed moved his family from Iran to Washington State. And for many reasons, most important things money, I had to find a job right away. While walking through town one day, his son pointed out a poster that advertised a job for a bus driver.
夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。特别感谢本期的声音设计师尼克·伍德伯里。我们今天的无名英雄来自我们的姐妹播客《我的无名英雄》。它来自听众马吉德·哈吉。2004年，马吉德把他的家人从伊朗搬到了华盛顿州。2004年，马吉德把他的家人从伊朗搬到了华盛顿州。出于种种原因，最重要的当然是钱，我必须立刻找到一份工作。一天，当他走过镇上时，他的儿子指着一张招聘公交车司机的海报。
And my son told me that they want a driver. You are a good driver, let's go for that. We called that number and we went to the interview as a matter of fact with my son because my English level wasn't that good for communicating with people that days. We went to the interview, they said, it's okay, we're looking for the driver as long as you pass the training session, which was one month long, and pass the driving test, you are okay. Magi went to the training every day and passed all the written portions. At the end of the month came the most important exam, the actual driving test. I already was under lots of pressure in very high anxiety level because of the job was
我儿子告诉我，他们想招个司机。你是个好司机，我们去应聘吧。我们拨打了那个号码，事实上我和儿子一起去参加了面试，因为我那时的英语水平还不足以和人正常交流。我们去面试了，他们说，没问题，我们正在寻找司机，只要你通过为期一个月的培训期，并能通过驾驶考试，就可以了。马吉德每天都去参加培训，并且通过了所有的笔试。一个月结束时，迎来了最重要的考试，也就是实际驾驶考试。
not just job for me, it was a kind of a very important point to bring money so fast to our saving bank which was going down very fast faster than I thought. And then I'm getting more anxious and anxious, but the peak of this anxiety comes when I saw the guy was responsible for to neck, and with the chain and everything, just cliché biker, which I knew from Hollywood movies. And I say, oh my god, I am doomed. And but the guy parked and he come to us and say, okay, get in the bus. Five at each time, five or six people at the time. Person by person get on the driver's seat and he start talking to them and say something which I didn't understand. Are they talking about last night movie movie or is it driving related things?
我当时承受着巨大的压力，焦虑水平极高，因为这份工作对我不只是工作，它是一个非常重要的转折点，能让我快速赚到钱存入我们的银行账户，而账户里的钱正在以比我想象的还要快的速度减少。然后我变得越来越焦虑，但这种焦虑的顶峰出现在我看到那个负责考核的家伙时，他带着文身，挂着链条，一切都符合好莱坞电影里那种标准的飞车党形象。我说，哦天哪，我死定了。但那家伙把车停好，朝我们走来，说，好啦，上车。每次五个人。一次上五六个人。一个人接一个人坐到驾驶座上，他开始跟他们说话，说了一些我听不懂的话。他们是在讨论昨晚的电影，
I didn't know. And I said, OK, my God, what can I do? Why I am shaking, why I am all my blood in my body, actually rushed through my head. And the guy looked at me and said, OK, let's back to the base. The tester drove the bus back to the terminal and asked everyone to get off, except for magic. Oh my God, he wanna test me differently
还是在说和开车有关的事？我不知道。我心想，天哪，我该怎么办？为什么我在发抖，为什么我体内的血液实际上都在往头上涌。那家伙看着我，说，好啦，回基地吧。考官把公交车开回了总站，并要求除了马吉德之外的每个人都下车。天哪，他想用不同方式测试我
because it's nobody started from the base, everybody started outside. I got behind the wheel, I was, maybe I was shaking, maybe I couldn't see I don't remember but he at this point he came beside me two feet at my right side and and say look at me I look at him and he said just drive that's the two words I never forgot. Just drive. And somehow I saw the light. Everything was shiny after that. He continued to using very small words like go right, go left, back in here, stop here. We have a lift, we have to operate too. He even asked me to operate the lift. He
因为没人是从基地出发的，大家都是从外面开始的。我坐到方向盘后面，我当时，也许我在发抖，也许我看不清了，我不记得了，但在此时，他来到我身边，就在我右侧两英尺的地方，说，看着我。我看着他，他说，只管开车。这就是我永远不会忘记的两个字。只管开车。不知怎的，我看到了光芒。在那之后一切都变得闪闪发光。他继续使用非常简单的词汇，比如向右拐、向左拐、倒车停在这里、在这里停下。我们还有一个升降机，也必须操作。他甚至让我去操作升降机。他
was no short on procedure. He was so pro. And then we back to the base, he got on and the first paper he was signed, he was my paper, say, magic past. And now let's see who else passes. He is my unsigned hero. For two reasons. One immediate effect on my family and I financial, with getting the job, having paycheck in two weeks and having hope to go through with our life in the new, our new country. The second reason came to Majeed later. He realized that he had stereotyped the tester because of his appearance.
在程序上一点也不含糊。他太专业了。然后我们回到基地，他上了车，他签下的第一份文件，就是我的文件，上面写着：马吉德通过。现在让我们看看还有谁通过。他是我的无名英雄。原因有二。一是对我和家人的经济产生了直接影响，得到了这份工作，两周内有了薪水，并且对在新国家继续生活有了希望。第二个原因马吉德后来才意识到。他意识到自己因为外表而对考官产生了刻板印象。
The kindness he received showed him the importance of not prejudging people. I find out whatever I think about people could be wrong and it was wrong. He is my unsung hero. For that reason, I can see people differently now. Listener, Majeed Hajj. Majeed lives in Seattle, Washington with his wife. He enjoys traveling the country and spending time with his kids. If you found this episode thought provoking, please do your part to keep us thriving. Help us build more shows for new listeners.
他所感受到的善良向他展示了不预先评判人的重要性。我发现我对别人的任何看法都可能是错误的，事实也确实如此。他是我的无名英雄。出于这个原因，我现在可以用不同的眼光看待人们了。听众，马吉德·哈吉。马吉德和他的妻子住在华盛顿州西雅图。他喜欢在这个国家旅行，并与孩子们共度时光。如果您发现这一集引人深思，请尽自己的一份力支持我们继续发展。帮助我们为新听众制作更多节目。
Visit support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Ben Şankar Vedantım. Siyasın. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再重复一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。Ben Şankar Vedantım. Siyasın. you 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。